the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi hopefully by now you have become well
experienced at computing limits of
double sums you've learned to hate me a
little bit more because the work was
quite complicated and hopefully you are
convinced that there must be an easier
way to do this stuff and fortunately the
answer is there is an easier way
sometimes and the concept that we're
going to talk about today is again
completely analogous to what happened in
calculus of a single variable where we
showed that the concept of definite
integral existed independently of being
able to form derivatives but in the case
where we knew a particular function
whose derivative would be a given thing
we were able to perform the infinite sum
are computing infinite sum much more
readily than had we had to rely on the
arithmetic of infinite series by the way
now I mentioned this later in a
different context I hope that the
converse problem was also true that in
many cases one did not know how to find
the required function with the given
derivative and in this case knowing how
to find the area by the limit process
was equivalent to how we were then able
to invent new functions which had given
derivatives essentially the difference
in point of view was the difference
between what we called the first
fundamental theorem of integral calculus
and the second fundamental theorem of
integral calculus as I said the same
analogy will hold here and let's get
into this now without further ado I call
today's less than the fundamental
theorem and what I'm going to do now is
to pretend that we never had the lecture
of last time that we have never heard of
an infinite sum and I'm going to
introduce what one calls the
antiderivative of a function of two
independent variables again keeping in
mind the analogy that for more than two
independent variables a similar
treatment holds and the exercises will
include problems that have more than two
independent variables the idea is that
when I write down this particular double
integral if I look at the innermost
integral notice that X appears only as a
parameter that the variable of
integration is y notice then that X is
there's a constant we pick what this
says is what pick a fixed value of x
compute this integral evaluate this as Y
goes from G 1 of X to G 2 of X the
resulting function is a function of X
alone and integrate that function of X
from A to B and to do that for you in
slower motion so you see what happens
here what I'm essentially saying is read
this thing inside out imagine some
brackets placed here not imagine them
let's put them in and what we're saying
is look at for first of all fix a value
of X hold X constant and for that fixed
value of x compute f of XY dy from G 1
of X to G 2 of X compute that that's a
funk remember that you're going to
integrate that respect to Y when you're
all through with this because the limits
involve only X the integrand that you
get in britain this bracketed expression
will now be a function of X alone
holiday chav x integrate h of x DX
between a and b and the resulting
expression assuming that you can carry
out the integration of course will be a
particular number right that has nothing
to do as I say with double sum so far
though I suspect that you're getting a
bit suspicious and the same way that the
definite integral was a sum and not an
antiderivative it looked enough like
this the notation of the definite
integral looked enough like the notation
of the indefinite integral so we began
to suspect there was going to be a
connection between them that connection
is what's going to be called the
fundamental theorem in our present case
but going on let me just give you an
example showing you how we compute how
we compute the antiderivative let's take
for example integral from 0 to 2
integral from 0 to x squared X cubed y
dy DX again we go from inside to out the
way we read this is that we're
integrating with respect to Y that means
we're holding X constant for a fixed
value of x integrate this as Y goes from
0 to x squared so treating X as a
constant I integrate this with respect
to Y the integral of Y dy is 1/2 Y
squared I evaluate that as Y goes from 0
2x squared that's crucial you see it's
why that goes from zero to x squared
when I replace Y by the upper limit I
get one-half X cubed times the quantity
x squared squared when I replace Y by
the lower limit 0 the integrand vanishes
so that what I wind up with is a
function of X alone specifically what
function is it it's one half X to the
seventh and I now integrate that from 0
to 2 that gives me 1/8 X to the eighth
over two that's X to the 8th over 16
evaluated between 0 & 2 2 to the 8th
over 16 is to the 8th over 2 to the 4th
which is to the fourth which in turn is
16 so again notice I can carry out this
operation purely manipulatively it is
truly the inverse of different a king
the partial derivative in the same way
that taking the partial derivative
involved holding all the variables but
one constant taking a partial integral
so to speak an antiderivative involves
simply doing what integrating treating
all the variables but the given one as a
constant which reduces you again to the
equivalent of what the antiderivative
meant in the calculus of a single
variable
now his where we come to the so-called
fundamental theorem let me tie what
we've talked about today and what we
talked about last time let me see if I
can tie those together for you in a
completely different way meaning I want
you to see that conceptually today's
lesson and last times lesson are
completely different but that the
punchline is there's a remarkable
connection between the tool but suppose
I take the region R which is a very
simple region that's bounded above by
the curve y equals G 2 of X it's bounded
below by the curve y equals G 1 of X and
that these two curves happen to
intersect at values corresponding to x
equals a and x equals B and what I would
like to find is the mass of the region R
if its density is some given function f
of X Y now in terms of what we did last
time
this involved a double some what double
some was it we partition this into
rectangles etc we picked a particular
number C sub IJ comma D sub IJ in the IJ
rectangle we computed F of C sub IJ
comma D sub IJ times Delta a sub IJ
added these all up the double somers I
went from 1 to N and J one went from 1
to M and took the limit as the maximum
Delta X I and Delta YJ approach zero and
that limit if it existed and it would
exist if F was piecewise continuous that
limit was denoted by what double
integral over the region are f of X Y da
and that da could either be viewed as
being dy DX if you wanted it could be DX
dy it could also be say in different
coordinate systems we're not going to
worry about that part just yet we'll
worry about that in future lectures now
on the other hand let's stop right here
for a moment let's see how one might
have been tempted to tackle this problem
from a completely intuitive point of
view the so-called engineering approach
if you had never heard of the
antiderivative but had had
antiderivative for several variables but
had taken part one of our course the
engineering approach would be something
like this you would say let's pick a
very small infinitesimal region here in
which we can assume that the density is
constant so we'll pick a little region
that's a very very small rectangle of
dimension what we'll say it's dy by DX
and the density of this particular
rectangle can be assumed to be the
constant value f of X Y because that
density is constant the mass of this
little piece should be f of X Y times dy
DX and then we say what let's add these
all up C let's go down to here now we
say limit this is a typical element and
we'll add them all up for all
wise and all possible axes now how would
you do this intuitively you'd say well
look at let me hold X constant well for
a constant value of X let's call X sub
one for a constant value of X notice
that Y can vary any place to be in the
region R for that fixed value of X Y can
be anyplace from here to here in other
words Y varies continuously from G 1 of
X 1 to G 2 of X 1 alright because X 1
could've been any X Y varies for that
given X Y varies continuously from G 1
of X to G 2 of X and notice that X could
have been chosen if we want to be in the
region R to be any place from A to B and
so mechanically we might say let's just
say here's the mass of a small element
and we'll add these all up so that for a
fixed X Y goes from G 1 of X to G 2 of X
and X can be anywheres from A to B and
it appears that this is a truism this is
not a truism it's a rather remarkable
result it is analogous to what happened
in calculus of a single variable namely
notice that when we had the definite
integral from A to B f of X DX
that was an infinite sum it was
summation f of C sub K Delta X sub K as
K went from 1 to n taken in the limit as
the maximum Delta X sub K approached
zero it turned out that if we knew a
function capital F whose derivative was
little F then this sum could be
evaluated by computing capital F of B
minus capital F of a again the idea
being that if you knew a function whose
derivative was F that gave you an easy
way to evaluate the sum on the other
hand if you could if you didn't know a
function whose derivative was little F
evaluating the sum as a limit gave you a
way of being able to find the
antiderivative a particular case on
point you may recall was trying to
handle the problem e to the minus x
squared DX as X goes from 0 to 1 this
certainly existed as an area but we did
not know in fact there is no elementary
function we invented one
the error function whose derivative is e
to the minus x squared so the idea is
and this is this is the key point this
is what becomes known as the fundamental
theorem for several variables that there
is a connection between a double
infinite sum and a double anti
derivative that this particular
expression here does not involve knowing
anything about partial derivatives this
particular expression here does not
involve being a any knowledge of knowing
partial sums this simply says what
integrate this thing twice once holding
X constant and letting Y go from G 1 of
X to G 2 of X and then integrating with
respect to X and the amazing result is
that if F is continuous this limit
exists and in particular if we happen to
know how to actually carry out these
repeated or iterated into integrations
we can compute this complicated sum
simply by carrying out this
antiderivative and I think the best way
to emphasize that to you is to repeat
the punchline to the homework exercises
of last assignments you may recall that
last time we were dealing with the
square whose vertices were 0 0 1 0 1 1
and 0 1 the density of the square at the
point X comma Y was x squared plus y
squared and I asked you as a homework
problem to compute the mass of this
plate R to compute exactly and what we
said was ok by definition of remember
this thing here now with the air under
here indicates a double limit of a
double sum that this mass was by
definition this particular result and
notice that last time we showed in terms
of double sums that this came out to be
2/3 let me show you in terms of our new
theory how we can find this much more
conveniently with no sweat so to speak
what I'm going to do now is the
following the same analogy I used before
I look at my region here which I'll call
I say what for a fixed value of x for a
fixed value of x notice that y varies
continuously from 0 to 1 see y varies
continuously from 0 to 1 and that x in
turn could have been chosen to be any
place from 0 to 1 that as we run through
all of these strips added up from 0 to 1
that covers our region R so what we're
saying is our write a little element of
our mass will be x squared plus y
squared dy DX we'll add these all up
from 0 to 1 holding X constant then add
them all up again as X goes from 0 to 1
again this is the iterated integral how
do we evaluate this well we treat X as a
constant integrate this with respect to
Y if we're treating X as a constant this
integral comes out to be x squared Y
plus 1/3 Y cubed and we now evaluate
that as Y goes from 0 to 1 leaving these
details out because they are essentially
the calculus of a single variable all
over again this turns out to be the
integral from 0 to 1 x squared plus 1/3
DX which in turn is 1/3 X cubed plus 1/3
X evaluated as X goes from 0 to 1 the
upper limit gives me 1/3 plus 1/3 the
lower limit 0 the mass here is 2/3 which
checks with the result that we got last
time again I'm not going to go through
the proof of the fundamental theorem I
don't think it's that crucial it's
available in text books on advanced
calculus some of the exercises may
possibly give you hints as to how these
results come about but by-and-large are
more interested now in you seeing the
overview and at this stage of the game
letting you get whatever specific
theoretical details you desire on your
own all right at any rate let's continue
on with examples I think a very nice
counter part to example 1 and to refresh
your memories without looking back at
example 1 asked us to compute this
antiderivative
and what I'd like to do now is to
emphasize the fundamental theorem by
Wooding this a different way what I want
you to what I want to do now is to
describe the plate are if it's mass is
given by what the double integral over
the region R Rho of XY da and that turns
out to be integral from 0 to 0 to x
squared X cubed y dy DX what is the
region R whose what is this region R if
this is how its mass is given the first
thing I want you to observe of course is
that this part here is identified with
the density part of the problem and that
these limits of integration determine
the region R for example what this says
is if you hold X constant Y varies from
0 to x squared let's see what that means
if you hold X constant Y varies from 0
well y equals 0 is the x-axis to y
equals x squared that's this particular
parabola what this says is for a fixed
value of x say x equals x1 the to be in
the region R you can be any place from
the x axis along the strip up to y
equals x1 squared so your strip is like
this then we're told that in turn x can
be chosen to be any place from 0 to 2 so
now what we know is that this strip
could have been chosen for any value of
x between 0 and 2 and what that tells us
therefore is that the shape of our
region R is the curve that's our the
region that's bounded above by the curve
y equals x squared below by the x-axis
and on the right by the line x equals 2
this is our region R you see the region
R is determined by the limits of
integration and the density of R is
given by Rho of X y equals x cubed y at
the point X comma Y ok by the way in we
had mentioned before that why do you
have to write dy/dx couldn't you have
written DX dy what I thought I'd like to
do for a nut for my next example for you
to show you how one inverts or changes
the order of integration for example
given the same integral the same region
are suppose we now want to express the
mass in the form double integral x cubed
y DX dy you see the region R is still
the same as it was before but now you
see what we want to do how would we read
this this says we're integrating with
respect to X X is varying so this says
for a fixed value of y integrate this
thing see for a fixed value of y
integrate this evaluated between the
appropriate limits of X in terms of Y
and then integrate this with respect to
Y well what this says is let's pick a
fixed value of y let's say y equals y1
for that fixed value of y notice that
the curve y equals x squared for X
positive in inverted form has the form x
equals the square root of y all right so
for a fixed value of y notice that X
varies from the square root of y 1 up to
x equals 2 C X goes from the square root
of Y to 2 for a fixed value of y now
where can Y be C this is a limits here Y
to be in the region are Y could have
been chosen as low as this or as high as
this in other words Y varies
continuously from 0 to 4 and again
because I don't want to have our lecture
obscured by computational detail I
simply urge you to on your own compute
this double integral compute the double
integral that we obtained in example
number 3 and show that the answers are
the same what I do want you to observe
is how different the limits look in
other words notice that in the other
integral it was from 0 the two outside
now it's from 0 to 4 notice also on the
inside integral it was from 0 to x
squared
now it's from the square root of Y to 2
there is no mechanical way of doing this
at least in the two dimensional case we
can see from a picture what's happening
in the multi-dimensional case we have to
resort to the theory of inverse
functions and this becomes at
a very messy procedure of course the
answer is if it's such a messy procedure
why bother with it and so in terms of
another example that I would like to
show you let me give you an illustration
in which it may be possible to find the
required answer if we integrate in one
order but not if we integrate with
respect to the other order let me
evaluate the double integral 0 to 2 X -
2 e to the Y squared dy DX again let me
see if I can at least write down what
this thing means geometrically before I
even begin notice that I can think of
this as a plate R whose density at the
point X comma Y is e to the Y squared
and what is the shape of this plate for
a fixed integrate with respect to Y
first for a fixed value event for a
fixed value of x y goes from y equals x
well that's this line here 2y equals 2
that's this line here so for a fixed X y
varies continuously from here to here X
can be any place from 0 to 2 that
happens to be the point 2 comma 2 where
the line and these two lines intersect
so the region R is this rectangular
region here okay this is our region R
and what we're saying is find the Mast
of the region R if it's density at the
point X comma Y is e to the Y squit now
notice that this density exists even if
I've never heard of the antiderivative
if however I elect to use the
fundamental theorem and I say ok what
I'll do is is I'll compute this notice
I'm back to an old Bugaboo I don't know
how to integrate e to the Y squared dy
other than by an approximation in terms
of elementary functions there is no
function whose derivative respect to Y
is e to the Y squared so what I do is I
elect to change the order of integration
why is that well because if I change the
order of integration sure I'm
integrating e to the Y squared but now
with respect to X which means that e to
the Y squared is a constant heck this is
trivial to integrate it's just going to
be x times e to the Y squared
problem is what if I'm going to change
the order here I must make sure that I
take care of the limits of integration
accordingly now what this says is what
I'm going to integrate respect to X
first X is going to vary so I'm treating
Y as a constant for that constant value
of y notice that to be in the region R
for that constant value of Y our X
varies from what x varies from zero to
the line y equals x or accordingly x
equals y so for that fixed value of x
I'm sorry for that fixed value of Y X
varies from x equals zero to X equal Y
and correspondingly Y can be chosen to
be any fixed number between 0 and 2 and
that gives me this particular double
integral and by the way from this point
on the rest is child's play because when
I integrate this you see this integrand
is X e to the Y squared when X is equal
to Y this this becomes X when X is equal
to Y this becomes Y e to the Y squared
when X is 0 the lower limit drops out so
what I want to integrate now is 0 to 2y
e to the Y squared dy but this is
beautiful for me because the factor of Y
in here is exactly what I need to be
able to handle this in other words this
is nothing more than 1/2 e to the Y
squared evaluated between 0 and 2
replacing Y by 2 gives me 1/2 e to the
fourth replacing Y by 0 remember e to
the 0 is 1 gives me minus 1/2 because
I'm subtracting the lower limit in other
words this the answer to evaluating this
integral which was impossible to do in
this form because of the fact that there
was no elementary function whose
derivative is e to the Y squared turns
out quite nicely to be given by e to the
4th minus 1 over 2 and to summarize
today's lecture to show you what the
fundamental theorem really means all
we're saying is that we often compute
the infinite double sum double integral
our f of X Y da by an appropriate
an integral that's what we mean it's
what the antiderivative integrating
taking the antiderivative successively
iterated integral see iterated integral
and conversely in other words the gist
of this whole thing is is that we now
have two entirely different topics that
are related by a fantastic unifying
thread that allows us to solve one of
the problems in terms of the other and
vice versa you see again the analogy
being complete with what happened in the
calculus of a single variable that we
can evaluate double sums which was the
aim of the previous lecture by means of
an iterated integral
we can evaluate iterated integrals
sometimes by appropriately knowing how
to find or by knowing how to find the
limit of an appropriate double sum and
again we shall make use of this in the
exercises we will go into this in more
detail from other aspects and other
points of view next time at any rate
until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate